en el último vídeo hicimos algunos
ejemplos donde teníamos un dígito que se
repetía por siempre y por siempre y por
siempre y fuimos capaces de convertirlos
en fracciones en este vídeo quiero
abordar algún poco más interesante que
son varios números repitiéndose una y
otra vez por siempre digamos por ejemplo
que tenemos el número cero punto 0.36
barra esto esto que significa pues
nuevamente que 36 se me está repitiendo
una y otra y otra y otra vez para
siempre muy bien entonces tendremos 0.36
36 36 y así sucesivamente nunca va a
acabar y entonces vamos a utilizar la
misma técnica vamos a llamarle a este
número una variable x muy bien entonces
el detalle es multiplicar por alguna
potencia de 10 digamos por 10 en mí lo
que sé yo de tal suerte que podamos
alinear los 36 36 36 que se repiten por
siempre entonces si nosotros movemos dos
unidades
los dos espacios el número decimal vamos
a poder hacerlo entonces necesitamos
multiplicar por 100 que es 10 al
cuadrado verdad entonces si
multiplicamos esto por 100 lo que vamos
a tener es que este número se recorre
dos espacios y tenemos 36 puntos 36 36 y
así sucesivamente muy bien entonces
vamos ahora a restarle x como lo hicimos
en el vídeo anterior restamos x y
entonces será lo mismo que restar 0.3
636 y así sucesivamente y hacemos la
cuenta
vamos a ver 100 x - x nos quedan 99 x
muy bien 100 100 de algo menos 1 de ese
algo pues me quedan 99 de ese algo y
ahora si restamos esto todos estos se
van a cancelar con estos de aquí son
exactamente igual y nos queda sólo 36
muy bien entonces x si dividimos de
ambos lados entre 99
lo que nos queda es que estos se
cancelan y me queda que x es igual a 36
entre 99 y como bueno podemos ver entre
que son divisibles ambos verdad y 36 es
divisible entre 9 y 99 también así que
dividimos entre 9 de ambos la de arriba
y abajo y nos queda 36 entre 9 es 4
verdad por 4 son 36 y 99 entre 9 y 11
así que este número el 30 el punto 36 36
36 36 es 4 11 ambos fue un número muy
sencillo vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
digamos que tengo yo ahora el número x
igual a 0.7 14 pero ahora quien se
repite solo es el 14 ok esto en términos
más prácticos es 0.7 14 14 14 y así
sucesivamente verdad entonces ahora
nosotros tenemos que multiplicar por
algo de tal suerte que se alinean y a lo
mejor tú estaría pintado a multiplicar
por mil verdad recorrerlo hasta acá pero
si tú lo haces de esa forma no se van a
alinear no se van a alinear así que
vamos a multiplicar nuevamente por 100 y
verás que aquí si se anula si se alinean
perdón entonces si multiplicamos por 100
vamos a recorrer este punto dos espacios
y vamos a tener 70 y 1.414 14 y así
sucesivamente verdad entonces restamos
la equis restamos x como siempre y
entonces en realidad prestamos 0 puntos
7 14 14 y así sucesivamente viste que
ahora sí sé que se alinearon en este
caso ok entonces otra vez vamos a restar
y tenemos 100 de algo menos 1 de ese
algo pues tenemos 99 de ese algo muy
bien y si restamos aquí los que se
cancelan son estos a partir de este
momento y ahora tenemos que restar que
71.4 menos 0.7 entonces aquí lo que
podemos hacer es digamos pedimos
prestado verdad éste se convierte en un
14 y éste se convierte en un 0 entonces
7 para 14 menos 7 es 7 para el punto
decimal y ahora tenemos 70 menos 0 son
70 y aquí a lo mejor tú dices hoy están
pasando cosas muy raras porque me quedo
un número decimal aquí y yo lo quiero
infracciones bueno vamos a seguir el
procedimiento y ahorita lo corregimos
entonces sí
entre 99 de ambos lados me queda que x
verdad esto se cancelan y que x va a ser
70.7 entre 99 entonces lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar arriba y abajo en
el numerador y en el denominador por
alguien de tales de tal forma que este
punto decimal se me recorra entonces en
realidad si yo multiplico por diez
arriba y por 10 abajo verdad si te das
cuenta aquí fue como multiplicar por 1 y
multiplicar por 1 al número no le hace
nada sin embargo lo que vamos a hacer es
que el numerador queda expresado en el
sin punto decimal y abajo también
entonces si multiplicamos estos dos nos
queda 707 entre 900 perdón 99 por 10 que
son 990 muy bien entonces ya tenemos la
solución vamos a hacer uno más
digamos que ahora tenemos el número x
igual a 3.200 57 y el 257 es periódico
es decir este se repite entonces
volvemos a hacer el mismo truco podemos
multiplicar por algo de tal suerte que
al restarlo se alinean y en este caso
pues coinciden muy bien con el mil mil
veces de este x va a ser
va a ser este se recorre 333 lugares
verdad 1 2 3 y entonces me queda 3.257
punto 257 257 257 y así sucesivamente
muy bien
entonces ahora si restamos x si le
restamos la equis en realidad estamos
restando hay que alinear el punto
decimal le estamos restando 3.257 257
257 y así sucesivamente verdad le
estamos restando esto acá me faltó
ponerle que le estamos restando muy bien
entonces qué es lo que me queda si yo
tengo un 1000 de algo y le restó 1 pues
nos quedan 999 de ese algo y si aquí
restamos esto si nos damos cuenta estos
se cancelan con todos estos y
simplemente me queda 3.257 menos 3 y que
esos son 3.254 muy bien entonces
finalmente ya podemos ver quién es x
porque x será si dividimos entre 999 de
ambos lados nos queda que x es 3.254
entre 990
muy bien entonces ahora podemos darnos
cuenta de que este número esta fracción
es impropia y si es impropia podemos
dividir y ver quién cuántos cuántas
cuántos enteros tiene digamos cuál es su
parte entera entonces digo también
podrías hacerlo de otras formas por
ejemplo decir que x es 3 + 0 punto 257
que se repite ver cuánto es eso y demás
pero bueno vamos vamos a hacerlo de esta
forma vamos a dividir tenemos 3.254
entre 999 y esto va a caber tres veces
para caber tres veces verdad pues sí más
o menos cabe tres veces entonces 3 por 9
son 27 y llevamos 2 3 por 9 son 27 y le
sumamos estos dos son 29
otros 23 por nueve son 27 y 2 son 29 y
ahora lo restamos los restamos y tenemos
el 4 es más chico que 7 entonces éste se
convierte en un 14 y éste se convierte
en un 4 y 14 menos 7 nos queda 7
ahora tenemos que 4 hay que restarle 9
este es más chico entonces le pedimos
prestado 1 al de la izquierda se vuelve
uno y tenemos 14 menos 9 son 5 son 5
ahora tenemos 19 otra vez es más chico
entonces éste se convierte en 11 porque
le pide prestado 1 al 3 y entonces 11
menos 9 son 2 y ahora nos queda dos
menos 2 son 0 y ya tenemos nuestra
respuesta porque esto simplemente será 3
enteros con 257 999